Hey everybody, it's Craig Thomas.
大家好，我是克雷格·托马斯。
I wrote a book and I want you to know about it, but instead of watching me or listening to me be self-promotional in a blatant and uncomfortable way.
我写了一本书，想让大家知道，但与其看我或听我进行那种厚颜无耻又让人尴尬的自我宣传……
I was delighted by this book.
我对这本书爱不释手。
It is super page-turny.
它真的超级吸引人，让人一页接一页停不下来。
It is like breathlessly and hilariously plotted.
它的情节设计既扣人心弦又充满喜感。
The interiority was just as rich and as fun as the plot twists.
角色的内心世界和情节反转一样丰富有趣。
His many years of crafting great narratives on television came to bear on this.
他多年来在电视领域创作精彩叙事的功底在这本书里得到了充分体现。
Your gifts as a novelist are just abundant.
你作为小说家的天赋简直太丰沛了。
I was so delighted by it.
我真的太喜欢它了。
It's incredibly vivid.
它极其生动。
You're really seeing it as you read it.
你在阅读时仿佛历历在目。
Even if you were my mortal enemy, I would be forced to.
哪怕你是我的死敌，我也会被迫……
I'd love you dearly.
我会深深地爱你。
You're one of my best friends, but I would be forced to concede that you had written a great book.
你是我最好的朋友之一，但我还是不得不承认你写了一本好书。
That is amazing.
这太惊人了。
I wish that could be a blurb on the book, even if Frank Thomas was my mortal enemy.
我真希望这能成为书上的推荐语，哪怕弗兰克·托马斯是我的死敌。
You will not be disappointed if you pick up this book or listen to this book, so check it out.
如果你买这本书或者听这本书，你绝对不会失望，快去看看吧。
And speaking of listening to this book, there is a mini How I Met Your Mother reunion in the audiobook of That's Not How It Happened.
说起听这本书，在《那是怎么发生的》的有声书中，有一个迷你的《老爸老妈浪漫史》重聚。
Listen to Kobe Smoltres.
听听寇碧·史莫德斯怎么说。
And so began the surreal, unholy process of my husband adapting my book, My Life, into a screenplay.
于是，我丈夫开始了我将我的书《我的一生》改编成剧本的超现实、神圣而又诡异的过程。
Here's another voice you may recognize, Josh Redder.
这里还有另一个你可能会听出来的声音，乔希·拉德纳。
Right now, I was in that pocket.
当时，我正处于那种状态中。
And as a writer, that's about as close to heaven as it gets.
作为一名作家，这几乎就是天堂般的享受了。
Okay, self-promotion over.
好了，自我宣传到此结束。
Now to this week's episode.
现在进入本周的节目。
It's a big one.
这期分量很重。
Ladies and gentlemen, how we met Neil Patrick Harris.
女士们先生们，我们是如何认识尼尔·帕特里克·哈里斯的。
me to tell you everything in New York City.
让我把纽约市的一切都告诉你。
Hello and welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother.
大家好，欢迎收听另一期的《老爸老妈浪漫史幕后故事》。
I'm Josh Ratner, your co-host, my other co-host.
我是乔希·拉德纳，你的联合主持人，还有我的另一位联合主持人。
I'm staring at his hands and face.
我正盯着他的手和脸。
Now his name's Craig Thomas.
现在他的名字叫克雷格·托马斯。
Hi, Craig.
嗨，克雷格。
Why?
为什么？
I'm blushing, sir.
我脸红了，先生。
Thank you.
谢谢你。
Do I not call you handsome enough?
难道是我平时夸你不够帅吗？
Not really enough.
其实不太够。
It's implied.
都在不言中。
I'm always feeling it.
我一直能感受到。
We made a TV show together years ago.
我们多年前一起制作了一部电视剧。
It started what, 20, 19 years ago.
它开始于，呃，20年前，19年前。
It was called How I Met Your Mother.
它叫《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
We did 208 episodes.
我们拍了208集。
It ran from 2005 to 2014.
它从2005年一直播到2014年。
We haven't seen it in years.
我们已经好多年没看过了。
We're going back through every single episode with our older, wiser eyes.
我们要带着如今更年长、更睿智的目光重新回顾每一集。
We're very proud of what we made for the most part.
大部分情况下，我们为我们所创作的内容感到非常骄傲。
And yeah, we're having a great time.
而且是的，我们度过了一段非常美好的时光。
And we always say this is a special episode.
我们总是说这是一集特别节目。
This is a special episode.
这是一集特别节目。
This isn't just such a special extra, extra special episode Because we have a man here who, it's just impossible to imagine the world of how I met your mother without.
这绝不仅仅是一集普通的、额外特别的节目，因为我们今天请到了一位嘉宾——没有他，简直无法想象《老爸老妈浪漫史》的世界。
He is the person who breathed life into the great iconic Barney Stinson and his name is Neil Patrick Harrison.
他就是为伟大而标志性的巴尼·斯廷森赋予生命的人，他的名字叫尼尔·帕特里克·哈里斯。
He's with us today.
他今天和我们在一起。
What?
什么？
Hey, Neil.
嗨，尼尔。
Please sit down, please, everyone sit.
请坐，请坐，大家都坐。
What's up, man?
最近怎么样，老兄？
Thank you.
谢谢。
Good to see you.
很高兴见到你。
It's nice to see your smiling faces.
很高兴看到你们笑脸相迎。
Oh my gosh, Alec as well.
哦天哪，还有亚历克。
Thank you for being here, buddy.
谢谢你能来，兄弟。
What have you been doing since 2014?
自2014年以来你都在忙些什么？
How have you been?
你最近过得怎么样？
I've been good, hookin'.
我过得很好，一直在接活。
I saw you, I saw your, you won a Tony, I saw that.
我看到你了，我看到你，你赢了一项托尼奖，我看到了。
I remember you jumped on my seat in the audience and you kissed me, I believe on the mouth.
我记得你当时从观众席跳到了我的座位上，而且我记得你亲了我的嘴。
For sure.
绝对有。
I think I got glitter on my face.
我想我的脸上还沾上了亮片。
Well, we had already, we'll talk about that.
好吧，我们已经……我们等会儿会聊到这个。
We had already broken that.
我们当时已经突破那个界限了。
And so you're living in New York City And let me just start with this.
所以你现在住在纽约市，让我先从这个聊起吧。
We talk about how the tale of this show, there were shows that were so popular when we were on the air, that people just do not talk about anymore.
我们经常谈到这部剧的传奇色彩，当我们还在播出的时有些剧非常火爆，但现在人们根本不再谈论它们了。
But for some reason, How I Met Your Mother is still very much in the zeitgeist, it's still in the culture.
但不知为什么，《老爸老妈浪漫史》依然深深烙印在流行文化中，它仍然活在文化里。
People still reference it, talk about it, discover it anew.
人们仍然在引用它、谈论它、并不断发现新的乐趣。
So I'm just curious, in your day-to-day life, you get recognized for a lot of things, but what's your experience of meeting how I met your mother fans?
所以我很好奇，在你的日常生活中，你因为很多事情被认出来，但你和《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝见面时的体验是怎样的？
and how has the show kind of changed in your perception of it as you've gotten more time away from it?
随着你与这部剧的距离越来越远，你对它的看法发生了怎样的变化？
Wow, an interesting question.
哇，这是一个很有趣的问题。
It's been constant, I mean, really, truly constant because when we did our final season, the show was on more times per day than ever.
这种经历一直都在，我是说，真的，实实在在地一直都在，因为在我们拍最后一季的时候，这部剧每天播出的次数比以往任何时候都要多。
So it was on three or four times a day in America.
它在美国一天要播三到四次。
And then when Netflix picked it up, it had another resurgence, and then it went somewhere else, then Netflix picked it up again, it had another resurgence.
然后当奈飞买下它时，它又迎来了又一次复苏；接着它去了别的地方，奈飞又把它买回去，它又迎来了又一次复苏。
Now, you know, I have my husband and I have twin 14-year-old children and their friends are watching it now, they're from high school.
现在呢，你知道的，我和我丈夫有14岁的双胞胎孩子，他们的高中同学现在也在看这部剧。
Are they watching it at Harper and Gideon watch it?
哈珀和吉迪恩也在看吗？
Yeah, for sure, so.
对，肯定的，所以。
Oh my God.
哦天哪。
So that's interesting because now that's a whole other level of like celebrity dynamic, but in a strange direction, because, you know, I want Harper and Gideon to be identified independently and they have their own, you know, triggers and issues with potentially only being recognized as the child of Barney Stinson.
所以这很有趣，因为现在这达到了另一种名人生态的层面，但却是一个奇怪的方向，因为，你知道的，我希望哈珀和吉迪恩能被独立地认可，他们有自己的，你知道的，潜在的心理负担和困扰，那就是只被当作巴尼·斯廷森的孩子来认出。
It's a complicated legacy.
这是一个复杂的遗产。
Yeah, for sure.
是的，确实如此。
It's a good and bad and it's something that they'll have to process.
它有好有坏，这也是他们以后需要去面对和消化的东西。
But I've had some really great marker chapters professionally in my life since then that have been super great and recognizable and fulfilling as well.
但从那以后，我在职业生涯中确实经历了一些非常棒的重要阶段，它们同样非常精彩、广为人知且充实。
But boy, yeah, people keep coming back to Barney and I'm so appreciative of it and I'm so grateful for the show because especially having played Barney, he was intended to be kind of the fifth wheel life of the party guy that you want to buy a drink and buy the next round and go on some crazy acid venture, right?
不过天哪，是的，人们总是不断谈论巴尼，我对此非常感激，我也非常感谢这部剧，尤其是扮演了巴尼这个角色——他本来被设定为那种“电灯泡”、聚会上的灵魂人物，是你想要请他喝一杯、再请下一轮、一起去进行某种疯狂的迷幻冒险的人？
That was how he was going to construct it, it seems.
看来剧本一开始是这样构思他的。
And so when I meet people who love the show, they're very positive and they're very enthusiastic and they have specifics and they tell me about the playbook and how many that they tried and that they met their girl doing the naked man and that they've been to the Liberty Bell, like, you know, it's, and a lot of people say that they have watched the show eight times.
所以当我遇到喜欢这部剧的人时，他们都非常积极、充满热情，而且他们能说出具体细节，还会跟我讲“情圣宝典”（The Playbook）、他们尝试过多少招式、他们通过“赤裸男”（The Naked Man）追到了他们的女孩、他们去过自由钟……你知道的，而且很多人说他们已经把这部剧看了八遍。
Yeah.
是的。
All the way through.
从头到尾刷完。
Do you ever have the experience that they're bringing up something that you're like, I don't remember that.
你有没有过这种经历：他们提起某个桥段，而你的反应是“我不记得了”？
Like they're they did something so specific, like they just watched it last night.
就像他们说得极其具体，仿佛他们昨晚才刚看过一样。
And you're like, I barely remember what you're talking about.
而你的反应是：我根本记不清你在说什么了。
For sure.
那是肯定的。
And and especially when someone comes up and they were on in the show, in an episode that had four or five lines.
特别是当有人走过来，而他们曾在剧中客串过，在只有四五句台词的一集里出现过。
You had a really awkward thing with Joe Manganello, you're like, I don't know this guy.
你和乔·曼根尼罗之间有过一件非常尴尬的事，你当时说，我不认识这家伙。
I haven't seen you before in my life.
我这辈子都没见过你。
But wow, look at your arms.
但是哇，看看你的胳膊。
And he takes his shirt off and you're like, oh, I remember this guy.
然后他脱下衬衫，你就说，哦，我想起这家伙了。
Oh yeah, that guy.
哦对，就是那家伙。
So no, it's just been, it's just been a delight.
所以，不，这真的，真的太令人高兴了。
It weirdly, I'm 52 years old, you know?
说来也怪，我都52岁了，你知道吗？
And people still consider me, will treat me as if I'm like vibrant, let's go have a great time and do fun things together.
人们依然认为我很，把我当成那种充满活力的人，我们去好好玩玩，一起做点有趣的事吧。
Yeah.
对。
And that's fun.
这很有趣。
Like it's fun to not be like the dusty older sage, but instead to still be like the one that can be devilish.
就像不用扮演那个古板的老智者，而是依然能做一个调皮捣蛋的人，这很有趣。
It was a devilish part.
那是一个很调皮的角色。
And I'm so grateful, Craig, to you and Carter, mostly to you, just because Carter's not here right now.
克雷格，我非常感谢你和卡特，主要是感谢你，只是因为卡特现在不在这里。
The feeling is very mutual.
我的感受完全一样。
Neil, I don't want to, I'm struggling with how much are a little too embarrassed to you during this.
尼尔，我不想，我正在纠结在节目里对你表现得是不是有点太害羞了。
But like each, every single episode we've done and we're at the end of season two almost now, every week we're saying like, how the fuck did Neil do that physical comedy thing or how did you find that moment?
但我们拍的每一集——现在几乎快到第二季末了——每周我们都在说，尼尔他妈的到底是怎么做到那种肢体喜剧的，或者你是怎么找到那个灵感的？
How, how does he do that turn on a dime the way he does?
他怎么能做到像他那样说变就变？
There's, we're, we're, we're fanning out on you a bunch rewatching our own show that we all made together.
我们，我们，我们都在为你着迷，一遍又一遍地重温我们大家一起制作的自己的节目。
So I just wanted to say that.
所以我只是想说这个。
Thank you, man.
谢谢你，老兄。
It was, it was one of those rare gifts that I'm sure you have talked about ad nauseam.
这，这是那种罕见的天赋之一，我确信你们已经翻来覆去地讨论过了。
where it was such a hybrid show at a time when that really didn't exist.
在那个这种形式并不真正存在的时代，它是一个如此融合的节目。
And so we were doing a multi-camera show with no audience as if there was an audience, and we were able to cut and reset and restart, and we were helmed by Pam Fryman, who was such like a heartbeat truthful sensor for everyone in their own ways, always.
所以我们在没有观众的情况下拍摄多机位节目，就好像有观众一样，我们能够剪辑、重置和重新开始，而且我们由帕姆·弗莱曼掌舵，她在各自的方面一直是每个人的心跳和真实感应器，始终如此。
And that North Star, I think, allowed everyone freedom to try shit and fail.
我认为，那个北极星般的指引让每个人都有自由去尝试各种胡闹并经历失败。
And the stuff that, I mean, I just felt like it was this back and forth between team writers room and team actor is they would sort of challenge us with like what, let's see if they, if this would be successful.
我的意思是，我觉得编剧团队和演员团队之间有一种来回的互动，他们会用诸如“让我们看看他们能不能成功”之类的事情来挑战我们。
And when it came to the Barney stuff, because, you know, Josh was so exquisite at the, at the pathos part and at making a laugh-tracked 22 minutes feel so sort of cinematic and real that then I was sort of gifted all of like the craziness and I was so fun to do because if it was a real sitcom with a multi-camera live studio audience it's a very different experience you rehearse all week and then it's show night and you really only have a couple cracks at it you do it and then you huddle up and the audience laughed at it, but they didn't laugh like you thought, so you write a bunch of stuff and then the guy is upstairs telling them, I'll give you chocolates if you laugh louder, and so then the second time you do it, it's like really big responses for everything and they're wanting to hear themselves when they go home later, so that's just a different vibe.
而当涉及到巴ney的桥段时，因为，你知道，乔什在表现悲情以及让带有罐头笑声的22分钟充满电影感和真实感方面是如此出色，所以我仿佛得到了所有疯狂桥段的天赋，演起来真的太有趣了。因为如果这是一个有现场多机位观众的真正情景喜剧，那将是完全不同的体验：你排练一整周，然后是演出之夜，你其实只有几次机会，你演完，然后大家聚在一起，观众笑了，但他们笑得和你想象的不一样，所以你重写了一堆东西，然后楼上的人告诉他们：“如果你笑得更大声，我就给你巧克力”，于是你第二次演的时候，所有东西都有了非常热烈的反应，他们希望以后回家时能听到自己的声音，所以这完全是另一种氛围。
We were able to do things five or six times.
我们能够把事情做五六遍。
And just trust what we felt.
并且只需相信我们的感觉。
Did we think it was good?
我们觉得它好吗？
Did our crew think it was good?
我们的剧组觉得它好吗？
It was we were the arbiters and I wanted to make the crew laugh was was paramount.
我们就是裁判，而我想逗笑剧组则是重中之重。
My favorite person to try and make laugh was Sue, our editor, because I know that she was the one pouring over all this stuff.
我最想逗笑的人是苏，我们的剪辑师，因为我知道她是那个字斟句酌地研究所有这些素材的人。
So I was I was I was constantly when we were filming trying to do little weird things that only she would acknowledge.
所以我，所以我，当我们在拍摄时，经常会做一些只有她才能注意到的古怪小动作。
She got the she had a whole relationship with you and I had a whole making it me.
她得到了，她和你建立了一种完整的关系，而我也在建立我自己的关系。
I feel weird that not for any other reason than I just could only imagine it's boring to be seeing like, which take do I do of these same similar five takes or something.
我觉得有点奇怪，原因无他，我只是觉得看这些相似的五个镜头到底用哪一个一定很无聊。
So I was just doing runner bits for her.
所以我只是在为她做一些连贯的小段子。
That was like the playful spirit that you brought to it.
你带给它的就是那种俏皮的精神。
You kind of didn't go out of character in between takes and Sue would watch, like not even takes just going like, what the fuck's Neil doing over here?
你在镜头之间甚至都不会出戏，苏会看着，甚至都不是在拍镜头，只是说：“尼尔在这儿他妈的在干什么？”
I think he's doing this just for me, but I think some of that energy makes it like that is the energy.
我想他这么做只是为了我，但我想这种能量的一部分让它变成了——那就是那种能量。
the energy of the weird little like mad scientist laboratory of making the show together.
一起制作节目的那个古怪的小疯狂科学家实验室的能量。
It's really cool.
真的很酷。
When you guys would write something like Barney sneezes the biggest sneeze that he's ever sneezed in his life.
当你们写出类似“巴ney打了一个他这辈子打过的最大喷嚏”这样的情节时。
That's all you'd say.
这就是你们说的全部。
I was like, oh, I love this game.
我就想，哦，我喜欢这个游戏。
Challenge accepted.
接受挑战。
I mean, literal challenge accepted.
我是说，字面意义上的接受挑战。
Neil, I remember we, when we watched episode three, Sweet Taste of Liberty, which was written by Miller and Lord, and Craig said that they said to him, What reminded me, Craig, they said this is where Barney is like an animated character.
尼尔，我记得我们，当我们看第三集《自由的甜美滋味》时，那是由米勒和洛德编剧的，克雷格说他们对他说过——这让我想起了什么，克雷格，他们说这就是巴ney像个动画角色的时候。
They said, we're going to make Barney a cartoon character in this one, and you don't want to burn it.
他们说，我们要在这一集里把巴ney变成一个卡通角色，而你不会搞砸的。
That wouldn't be every episode, but to do it in that one, the third episode of the entire series to say, this is a Barney cartoon adventure, trust us where Chris and Phil, we will make this fantastic.
这不会是每一集都有的，但在那一集里做这件事——整个系列的第三集——就像是在说，这是一场巴ney的卡通冒险，相信我们，克里斯和菲尔，我们会把它变得棒极了。
And that was so good.
而那真是太棒了。
So early, they called that shot.
他们那么早就定下了这个基调。
They really brought it in.
他们真的把它实现了。
I remember there was a moment where I was standing on the street and you pull up, I think in a limo or a tattoo, you pull up in a taxi and you were just like, get in, you know, you're demanding that I get in.
我记得有个时刻我站在街上，你把车开过来，我想是一辆豪华轿车或是一辆出租车，你把车开过来，然后你就说，上车，你知道的，你要求我上车。
And there was a look in your eye that was like new, that I was like, oh, Neil's dropped in like to another level of this character.
你的眼神里有一种类似于尼尔的东西，让我觉得，哦，尼尔已经进入了这个角色的另一个层级。
Like, yeah, like I just remember like you knew, you were about to take Ted, but you were about to take the episode and like make it insane.
就像，是的，就像我只记得你当时心知肚明，你即将带上特德，但你要把这一集推向疯狂。
And I just, that was the one, we are international businessmen on a business trip.
我只是，那是关键所在，我们是去出差的国际商人。
You remember that?
你还记得吗？
Yeah, yeah, which kind of like there's certain episodes we've noticed are like hope and Crosby road movies, like Old Timey, Walter Mathow, Jack Lemmon, kind of like just old timey buddy comedy movies.
对，对，就像我们注意到某些集数有点像霍普和克罗斯比的公路电影，有点像老派的沃尔特·马修、杰克·莱蒙那种老式的哥们喜剧电影。
But I just wanna also shout out that even if you conceived of yourself as like fifth guy party guy, you know, one thing that I really loved that because we got so long to do it that Craig and Carter did, they gave me some like insane animated shit to do, but they also gave you some real heart forward stuff that was just as moving as any other characters, as you get deeper in with your father issues with, we just look at the episode, oh no, is this?
但我还想大声称赞的是，即使你把自己设想成第五个派对狂人，你知道，我真的很喜欢的一点是，因为我们有很长的时间来做这件事，克雷格和卡特让我去做一些疯狂的动画烂摊子，但他们也给了你一些真正走心的东西，和任何其他角色一样感人，随着你和父亲之间的问题越来越深入，我们来看看那一集，哦不，是这一集吗？
Oh yeah, showdown.
哦对，摊牌。
In theory, we're talking about showdown.
理论上，我们在谈论摊牌。
At some point, we'll name check it and this comes in.
在某个时刻，我们会点出它的名字，然后这个情节就出现了。
The end of showdown when you reveal how Barney actually lost his virginity, but then he prefers the fantasy of that it was dirty dancing or whatever.
《摊牌》的结尾，当你透露巴ney实际上是怎么失去童贞的，但他更喜欢那是《辣身舞》之类的幻想。
Right, right, right.
对，对，对。
Yeah.
是的。
There's something so sad and moving but extra hilarious about like the tragedy at the heart of this man.
在这个男人的内心的悲剧背后，有些东西是如此悲伤和感人，却又格外滑稽。
And we talk a lot about, you know, Shannon and the Peace Corps and how Barney became Barney.
我们聊了很多，你知道，关于香农和和平队，以及巴ney是如何成为巴ney的。
But underneath it, he's just like a scared kid who didn't have a male role model in his life who's just like trying a piece together this like way to be a man in a way that's just kind of like insane.
但在这一切之下，他其实只是一个害怕的小男孩，生活中没有男性的榜样，只是试图拼凑出一种成为男人的方式，而这种方式简直有点疯狂。
But he also like, he ultimately has a good heart.
但他也，他最终有一颗善良的心。
And that's what he keeps seeing on this rewatch.
这就是他在这次重温中不断看到的东西。
And I wrote you, this little ditty, to sing to you, in New York City, will be right back.
我为你写了这首小曲，要在纽约市唱给你听，我们马上回来。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·拉德克。
You might know me from Bravo's Summer House, but on my podcast, More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
你可能通过 Bravo 电视台的《夏日别墅》认识我，但在我的播客《更多生活》中，我让你们最喜欢的真人秀明星们卸下工作，进入那些你平时听不到的对话中。
The deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
那些深刻的事情，那些脆弱的事情，那些让人不自在的事情。
I've sat down with Sierra Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我曾与西拉·米勒、多琳达·梅德利、汤姆·施瓦茨、林赛·哈伯德以及更多人坐在一起畅谈。
We get into relationships growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们深入探讨了成长过程中的人际关系、那些一团糟的事情，以及摄像机没拍到时发生的一切。
New episodes of More Life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts or watch on YouTube.
每周都有《更多生活》的新节目，请在各大播客平台收听，或在 YouTube 上观看。
And now, back to the show.
现在，让我们回到节目中。
I've always felt that he was kind of broken, and a lot of the show was, as the seasons went on was like revealing elements of his, you know, he never talked about his job.
我一直觉得他是那种破碎的人，随着季数的推进，节目的很大一部分就像是逐渐揭示他内心的元素，你知道的，他从未谈论过他的工作。
He never spoke.
他从不提及。
And as we're running gags of like, please.
随着我们不断玩梗，比如，拜托。
And so you never really knew much about him.
所以你从不知道关于他太多的事。
And that seemed like a good, a good place to hide sincerity and pay those.
这似乎是一个隐藏真诚和悲情的绝佳地方。
And I keep in mind up and tell how I met your mother.
我记住并讲述了《老爸老妈的浪漫史》。
I hadn't done what I mean, I did a wacky sitcom with Tony Shalub on NBC a few years before how I met your mother.
我还没做过——我的意思是，在《老爸老妈的浪漫史》几年前，我在 NBC 和托尼·夏鲁卜拍过一部古怪的情景喜剧。
one season and I was like the David Hyde Piercy kind of afraid of germs and an uptight guy and so that was fun but sort of very singular but I had never really done a lot of the big comedy stuff so I had mostly done like Dewey Houser was super sincere and a lot of television movies that had been like I was grounded in sincerity.
只拍了一季，我扮演的是那种类似大卫·海德·皮尔斯的、有点洁癖且古板的家伙，所以那很有趣，但非常单一，而且我从未真正演过很多大型喜剧，所以大多数时候我都演过，比如《天才小医生》超级真诚，还有很多电视电影，我的表演都扎根于真诚。
I feel like you had to do before Barney you did a lot of of what I had to do on How I Met Your Mother, which is kind of be the virtuous center of a show.
我觉得你在巴ney之前不得不做的事，很多就是我在《老爸老妈的浪漫史》里不得不做的事，那就是成为一个节目的道德中心。
And I felt there was something about, like you recognize the opportunity to be unleashed.
我觉得有种感觉，就像你意识到了被彻底释放的机会。
For sure.
那是肯定的。
To be like, oh my God, I, there was something about Barney, both the fact that he wore a lot of armor, like you're describing, like he had a lot of armor up.
就像，哦天哪，我，关于巴ney有一种感觉，既在于他穿着厚重的盔甲，就像你所描述的那样，他竖起了很多盔甲。
The suit was like an armor for him.
西装就像是他的盔甲。
But he also, the way he was constructed and the way you played him.
但同时，他的构建方式以及你扮演他的方式。
And I, you know, I think we developed these characters with the writers, it was a real team effort, but the way you gave him permission to be as insane as a human could possibly be and still actually be recognizable as a human, I'm just very impressed with it on this rewatch.
而且我，你知道，我认为我们和编剧一起塑造了这些角色，这是一次真正的团队合作，但你赋予了他像人类一样疯狂、同时又真正能被认作是人类的许可，在这部重温中，我对此印象深刻。
I appreciated it on set, but the more I watch it, and especially, this is something we talk about a lot, your physical comedy on the show is just unbelievable to watch.
我在片场就很欣赏这一点，但看得越多，尤其是——这是我们经常讨论的一点——你在剧中的肢体喜剧简直不可思议。
I remember the marathon episode where he's like, I can just, where you don't train for a marathon, you just run it, right?
我记得马拉松那一集，他说，我完全可以——你根本不为马拉松进行训练，你直接去跑，对吧？
And then his legs give out on the subway.
然后他的双腿在地铁里瘫软了。
The shot that they showed was above the window, because it's like really funny you try to get up.
他们展示的镜头是从窗户上方拍的，因为你试图站起来的样子真的很好笑。
But I was watching, I was on set in the scene, and I'm watching through the door, so I actually saw your legs not work in a way that I was like, how did he do that?
但我当时在看，我在片场的那个场景中，我透过门看着，所以我实际上看到你的双腿完全使不上劲，当时我就想，他是怎么做到的？
Like, I didn't even understand, literally, physically.
就像我甚至都不理解，字面意义上，身体上。
You so believe you were about to stand up.
你太坚信自己马上要站起来了。
Yes, the top half of your body was doing one thing, and the bottom was doing something completely different.
对，你的上半身在做一件事，下半身却在做完全不同的事。
It got us thinking, Josh, I think we're both one of NASA's questions.
这让我们开始思考，乔斯，我觉得我们俩都是美国宇航局的某种研究对象。
We're just wondering, we so love your physical comedy.
我们只是在想，我们太喜欢你的肢体喜剧了。
We were just wondering, did you grow up idolizing any physical comedians?
我们只是想知道，你成长过程中有崇拜过什么肢体喜剧演员吗？
Were you a Buster Keaton guy?
你是个巴斯特·基顿迷吗？
I've never asked you this, and we're really curious.
我从来没问过你这个，我们真的很好奇。
A massive physical comedy fan.
一个超级伟大的肢体喜剧粉丝。
Buster Keaton was a huge inspiration, Harold Lloyd, Charlie Chaplin.
巴斯特·基顿是一个巨大的灵感来源，还有哈罗德·劳埃德，查理·卓别林。
But then it really pivoted when I went and saw the second ever version of Cirque du Soleil's traveling show in Santa Monica.
但后来当我去看太阳马戏团在圣莫尼卡的巡演的第二个版本时，情况真的发生了转变。
At the Santa Monica Pier and it was called the Novette ex-Pierliance, the New Experience.
在圣莫尼卡码头，它被称为 Novette ex-Pierliance，也就是“全新体验”。
And it was the first time I had, well, it was the second time I'd seen Cirque because I'd seen their first show randomly there at that same spot.
那是我第一次，哦，其实是我第二次看太阳马戏，因为我之前在那同一个地方偶然看过他们的第一场演出。
And I'd never seen a circus with no animals.
我从来没见过没有动物的马戏。
And it was surrounded by this central figure who was a clown.
而且它围绕着一个核心人物，他是一个小丑。
And the clown was a performer named David Shiner.
那个小丑是一个名叫大卫·沙纳（David Shiner）的表演者。
And David Shiner is a very well-known clown.
大卫·沙纳是一个非常著名的小丑。
And one of his main things that he did was he was played as director.
他做的主打事情之一就是扮演导演。
And he wouldn't talk as the clown.
他作为小丑是不会说话的。
His clown spirit was very dismissive and annoyed at things.
他的小丑精神对很多事情都表现得非常不屑和恼火。
So there was a lot of like annoyance with things.
所以有很多那种对事物的烦躁情绪。
And so, and he would whistle a lot.
然后，他会经常吹口哨。
So he'd whistle and he would say, I'm going to do like he would mime that I'm going to make a movie.
所以他会吹口哨，然后他说，我要做——就像他会用哑剧表演我要拍一部电影。
And I need three people in the audience.
我需要观众席里的三个人。
And he had a big doorframe was his big center prop.
他有一个大门框作为他的核心大道具。
And he would say, I, he would mime.
然后他会说，我，他会用哑剧表演。
I need a sua, a studly guy that's going to come up and he would pick someone in the audience.
我需要一个帅哥，一个会走上台的健美帅哥，然后他会在观众中挑一个人。
Then he would pick a woman from the audience.
然后他会在观众中挑一个女人。
And then he would have them do a scene together.
然后他会让他们一起演一出戏。
They'd walk up and they'd kiss.
他们走上台去接吻。
And then there was a third guy who was like the nerdy guy and his David China's physical comedy was so next level.
然后还有第三个家伙，就像个书呆子，大卫·沙纳的肢体喜剧真的是高出好几个层级。
And I had never in my life been in a, like it was a circus arena so filled with people literally everywhere.
我这辈子从来没有在一个地方呆过，就像那是一个到处都坐满了人的马戏大帐篷。
And we were all laughing so hard for so long at his physical prowess, at his ability to transform his body from suave to debonair to nerdy to angry and he was a master at it and I was just from that point forward obsessed with David Shiner and Cirque du Soleil and it was a profound...
我们所有人都为他的肢体技巧、他将自己的身体从温文尔雅转变为风流潇洒、书呆子气再到愤怒的能力，笑了那么久、那么大声，他是这方面的天才，从那一刻起，我就对大卫·沙纳和太阳马戏团着迷了，这是一次深刻的……
Didn't he do stuff with Bill Erwin weren't they like a co-founder and Bill Erwin?
他不是和比尔·欧文（Bill Irwin）一起合作过吗？他们是不是和比尔·欧文算联合创始人？
They did and you can track those down probably on Broadway World or Broadway, there's It was like a channel that you could watch.
他们做过，你大概可以在百老汇世界（Broadway World）或百老汇找到这些，有一个类似频道你可以看。
It was called Fool Things.
它叫《滑稽玩意儿》（Fool Things）。
No, Fool Things.
不，滑稽玩意儿。
Fool Moon, one of my favorite things I've ever seen.
《滑稽月亮》（Fool Moon），我见过的最喜欢的节目之一。
Oh, Fool Moon, yeah.
哦，《滑稽月亮》，对。
Fool Moon, that's right.
《滑稽月亮》，没错。
They also did old hats later on, which was also fantastic.
他们后来还做过《老戏骨》（Old Hats），也超级棒。
How old were you in the story, Neil?
尼尔，发生这个故事的时候你多大？
How old were you when you got the, when this hit you were you a kid?
当你遇到这个，当这个击中你的时候你多大，你还是个孩子吗？
In that story?
在那个故事里？
Or you had 12 years old, 11, 12 years old.
或者你12岁，11、12岁。
That's great.
太棒了。
And then I went down a Bill Irwin loop because he did the very famous mime clown bit inside the trunk, where he would open up a wardrobe trunk and he would go down the steps and turn and go down the steps and he would become an elevator and like, we've all seen versions of it and his is undeniably like one of the best.
然后我开始深入研究比尔·欧文，因为他在行李箱里做过那个非常著名的哑剧小丑片段，他会打开一个衣柜行李箱，然后走下台阶转身又走下台阶，然后他会变成一部电梯，就像我们都看过各种版本，而他的无疑是最好的之一。
Were you already into magic at this point?
在这个时候你已经喜欢上魔术了吗？
I was in a magic, I was a self-taught juggler And so I just really, I really value how one's physicality can inform a scene.
我那时在玩魔术，我是一个自学成才的杂耍艺人，所以我真的很看重一个人的形体动作如何能为场景增色。
And so when you get the op, because words are super important, a paramount, right?
所以当你有机会——因为台词超级重要，是至高无上的，对吧？
And then inflection and what you do with those words is super important, but how you're standing, where you're looking.
然后语调以及你用这些台词做什么超级重要，但你是怎么站的，你看向哪里。
Like if you watch a close up of amazing performers and when they're talking a single tear, like drips out of their eye and their face doesn't move, like that is physical performing in its own right, they know, which there's actors that are like, you want a tear, which eye?
就像如果你看优秀演员的特写镜头，当他们在说话时，一滴眼泪从他们的眼中滑落，而他们的脸纹丝不动，这本身就是纯粹的肢体表演，他们懂的，有些演员会说，你想要一滴眼泪？哪只眼睛？
And that is impressive to me, right?
这对我来说很impressive（印象深刻），对吧？
Because I think it's part of the skill set.
因为我认为这是技能组合的一部分。
And I was always with how I met your mother loving the sandbox that we were in because we were a situation comedy, you know?
而且我在拍《老爸老妈浪漫史》时一直都很喜欢我们所在的这个沙盒，因为我们是一部情景喜剧，你知道吗？
And so I was so- It's so interactive.
所以我当时太——太有互动性了。
Because what we see you doing is writers.
因为我们看你做的是编剧的工作。
You were giving the writers that sign, like give me stuff, challenge me, stump me, stump the band.
你会给编剧发出信号，比如给我来点料，挑战我，难倒我，难倒乐队。
I dare throw me something.
我敢你朝我扔点什么。
I dare you to find something I can't do and we fucking couldn't.
我敢你找出一样我做不到的事，而我们他妈的还真找不出来。
I didn't think of it in that right.
我当时不是从那个角度去想的。
I didn't think of it in like a, of a competition sort of vibe.
我没把它想成是一种比赛之类的氛围。
What's the episode where Neil just has like different ways he's killing himself with miming like he does the what's the thing where you cut out where yeah yeah myself and then the blood coming out you did the blood coming out of your neck but even that one meal where we show who Barney was before he became Barney ready the episode where he becomes Barney like the Darth Vader or that that episode when we meet you as hippie Barney who's head over heels in love with Shannon your body the way you walk The way you walk is gonna be burning with the long hair.
哪一集是尼尔只是用各种不同的方式通过哑剧让自己“死”掉的？比如他做了那个——那个叫什么来着，你切断了——对对，切了自己然后血喷出来，你做了血从脖子里喷出来的动作。但甚至还有那一集，尼尔，当我们展示巴尼在成为巴尼之前的样子，准备好了吗？我们遇到你的那一集，你变成了嬉皮士巴尼，对香农神魂颠倒，你的身体，你走路的方式。你走路的方式，长头发的巴尼。
Yeah.
对。
The hair is doing the walking.
头发在带路。
The wig is leading the walk.
假发在带路。
Were we wondering, did you have the flu when you were filming that or something like, wasn't something crazy?
我们当时在想，你拍那一集的时候是不是得了流感还是怎么的，是不是有什么疯狂的事？
Yeah, I think you were dead sick that week and you fucking crushed it anyway.
对，我觉得那一周你病得要死，但你他妈的还是完美完成了。
It was like, are the biggest burning episode today because you had so much to do in that episode and you got the flu, the second that production week began, I think, and you were like, I am, guys, I'm sorry, I'm not gonna be that great this week.
当时就像是，这是迄今为止巴尼戏份最多的一集，因为那一集里你要做的事太多了，而且制作周刚一开始你好像就得了流感，然后你说，伙计们，对不起，这周我可能表现不会太好。
And then you were so fucking good.
然后你他妈的演得太棒了。
It was almost annoying.
简直有点气人。
It's like, how is he this good when he's, when he's, But I kind of remember that because it was all of the granola, yeah, Barney.
就像是，当他生病的时候他怎么能这么棒？但我有点记得那个，因为全是麦片，对，巴尼。
Yeah, you were the hippie guy and you had so much.
对，你是个嬉皮士，而且你有那么多戏。
When I was doing that stuff, Nicaragua, when you said need.
当我做那些事时，尼加拉瓜，当你说了“need”的时候。
Nicaragua.
尼加拉瓜。
But just your physicality changes so much and you like your then it's you were seeing you bridge between hippie Barney becoming Barney like we see that walk almost like Kaiser so is they like becoming Barney walking down the street.
但只是你的形体变化太大了，然后你就像是在看到你从嬉皮士巴尼过渡到巴尼，就像我们看到那个走路的姿态，有点像《非常嫌疑犯》里的凯撒·苏亚莱（Keyser Söze），像那样走过街道。
Every part of that is a masterclass in physical comedy.
这其中的每个部分都是肢体喜剧的教科书级别示范。
So it's just.
所以这只是——
Oh, that's so sweet.
哦，太贴心了。
That's so.
太——
you guys say that not that I was seeking that acknowledgement at all, but it's like I wasn't by any time if you were feeling low in one compliment.
你们能这么说——倒不是说我多么渴望得到这种认可，但就像，我当时其实并没有——如果在什么时候你觉得情绪低落，来个夸奖。
I wasn't doing it.
我当时并不是为了那个。
You know, it felt a little also like Saturday Night Live what we were doing because it was every week new stuff.
你知道，我们做的事情感觉也有点像《周六夜现场》，因为那是每周都有新东西。
And so I didn't really ever process it like, how can I win this or how can I you think you can write something that I can't do then I'll show you.
所以我从来没有真正把它当成什么“我该怎么赢过这个”或者“你以为你能写出我做不到的东西，那我就做给你看”。
I was just loving the softball lobs, right?
我当时只是喜欢这种轻而易举的投球，对吧？
And I also appreciated, and I think we all did, the notion that we were hopeful that this would be watched more than once.
而且我也很感激，我想我们大家都一样，那就是我们希望这个节目会被不止看一次。
And for most of its first four seasons, we were very unsure whether that was going to happen.
在前四季的大部分时间里，我们很不确定这是否会发生。
And yet, with these things, I would still, yes, I was doing it for Sue, the editors, so that she'd laugh.
然而，面对这些事情，我依然会——是的，我这么做是为了苏（Sue，指剪辑师），为了逗她笑。
But I also thought if If anyone wants to watch the repeat of the be fun for them to notice something new and different, instead of just like a great train doing a singular thing.
但我也觉得，如果有人想看重播，能注意到一些新的、不同的东西，而不是仅仅像一列伟大的火车在做一件单一的事情，那对他们来说会很有趣。
Yeah.
对。
We talked a lot in the first season, especially Neil, about how if the show had been a hit right out of the gate and there were so many eyeballs on us, it might have been a less interesting show.
我们在第一季的时候聊了很多，尤其是尼尔，关于如果这部剧一炮而红，有那么多双眼睛盯着我们，它可能会是一部没那么有趣的剧。
It might have developed into a less interesting show because we were kind of like good enough in the demo that we stayed on the air, but we weren't being noted to death.
它可能会发展成一部没那么有趣的剧，因为我们在收视群里的表现刚好够留在荧幕上，但我们没有被过度关注到死。
We weren't known as paying that much attention to us.
我们没有被认为受到那么多的瞩目。
we got to develop this really cool style.
我们得以发展出这种非常酷的风格。
So by the time people started watching us, we'd already really found our voice, the ensemble was like so gelled, like we were in the pocket, you know?
所以当人们开始看我们的节目时，我们其实已经找到了自己的声音，演员阵容也已经完美融合，就像我们找到了状态，你知道吗？
That's very, very true.
这非常非常真实。
We talked sometimes, Neil, about how, and almost seems like in certain moments where you're playing Barney, it's like Barney's the only one of these characters who knows he's in a sitcom.
有时候我们聊起，尼尔，关于——在某些时刻当你扮演巴尼时，感觉巴尼是这些角色中唯一一个知道自己身处情景喜剧的人。
I think Josh made that observation.
我想是乔斯提出了这个观察。
You give that great speech about where there's a drunk woman with daddy issues, we will be there.
你发表了那段精彩的演讲，大意是：哪里有个带着恋父情结的醉酒女人，我们就会出现在哪里。
We will be there.
我们就会出现在那里。
Remember that, like we will be there.
记住这一点，就好像我们会去现场一样。
But you walk in sometime at the beginning of season two and you walk in and you turn to the fourth wall.
但你在第二季开始的某个时候走进来，走进来，然后面向第四堵墙。
And I said, Neil is holding for applause.
我说，尼尔在等着掌声呢。
He's holding for applause.
他在等着掌声。
He thinks he's gonna get entrance applause, which if we had been in front of an audience, you would have.
他以为自己能赢得入场掌声，如果我们在观众面前的话，确实会的。
But it led me to this very meta question where I said, was Barney the only character who was aware he was in a sitcom?
但这让我提出了一个非常元叙事的问题，我当时说，巴尼是唯一一个意识到自己身处情景喜剧中的角色吗？
Like everyone else thinks they're living life.
就像其他人以为自己在过着真实的生活一样。
Barney is on some level new, he was in a weird reality.
巴尼在某种程度上，处于一种奇异的现实中。
So I never really acknowledge, I never really thought of it as if Barney is in a meta way, knows he's talking to the TV audience at home, but from the, from the pilot, it was clear that he loved his own catchphrases, needed to have his own catchphrases.
所以我从不觉得巴尼是以一种元叙事的方式知道自己在跟电视机前的观众说话，但从试播集开始，就很明显他热爱自己的口头禅，而且必须要有自己的口头禅。
And he'd been in that, in the Philly episode, I think that's when he does the lactose intolerance long, long version of legend, wait for it, Derry.
而且他在费城那一集里，我觉得就是在那一集里，他把“传奇”的“等一下”和“大”字拖得老长，搞了个乳糖不耐受的长版。
Yeah, and so he loved these and and there were lots of times when Barney would slowly like He would be writing normal you'd write normal jokes, but then you'd write a big paragraph of a thing that he would say Yeah, and so it was I think Barney did always feel like Like he was that in this new this story He was delusional and that the illusion was wait wait no matter what's happening in the world right now This is this is how it's going to be narrated and this is going to and so I think I would stand up and play to this this invisible fourth wall, which certainly would seem like it was the audience day in the world.
是的，所以他很喜欢这些，而且有很多时候巴尼会慢慢地……他会写正常的，你会写正常的笑话，但接着你会写一大段他要说的话，对，所以我觉得巴尼总是让人感觉，好像在这段新故事里，他是产生幻觉了，而这种幻觉就是，不管现在世界上发生了什么，事情都会以这种方式被叙述，事情将会……所以我觉得我会站出来，对着这个看不见的第四堵墙表演，这在当时的世界里肯定看起来就像是对着观众一样。
I agree with what you're saying so much because he's obsessed with the idea of audience and how things appear, like this night that is legendary and people will talk about this for ages.
我太赞同你说的了，因为他对观众的概念以及事情呈现出来的效果有着一种痴迷，比如这个传奇的夜晚，人们会谈论这件事好久。
He's very much like, we're the main characters and we're gonna create the best.
他非常坚信：我们是主角，我们要创造最棒的体验。
And even, you know, Mapeep's Needin' But tweets, the stuff about his blog, Like he was very into like image management and also having it look a certain way.
甚至，你知道的，还有“Mapeep's Needin'”的推文、关于他的博客的内容，他非常热衷于形象管理，并且还要让它呈现出某种特定的效果。
He knows it's gonna be a story.
他知道这会成为一个故事。
So he's going to be the star of the story.
所以他要成为故事的主角。
He's going to make the story happen.
他要让故事发生。
Or at least the motor for the weirdest parts of the story.
或者至少是推动故事中最诡异部分的核心动力。
He's talking to the future versions of themselves that are gonna, that's the fourth wall of the future.
他在和未来版本的自己对话，那些将会……那是未来的第四堵墙。
And I felt a little bit of freedom as well because the structure of the show was Ted telling not the true story, but his remembrance of the story.
而且我也感到了一点自由，因为节目的结构是泰德讲述的不是真实的故事，而是他对故事的回忆。
And so I didn't feel ever like I needed to be doing what really happened, but I'm doing what Ted was telling his kids how it happened.
所以我从来不觉得我需要表现出真正发生的事，而是在表现泰德告诉他孩子们事情是怎么发生的。
So I did feel that I had an agency to be bigger and to say things as if he was the life of the party, not in a real world, because Ted was explaining it, right?
所以我确实觉得我有主动权去表现得更夸张，把事情说得好像他是派对的灵魂人物，不是在现实世界里，因为这是泰德解释的版本，对吧？
It's right, it's not reality, it's memory.
没错，这不是现实，这是记忆。
And this is the how Barney occupies future Ted's memory.
这就是巴尼在未来的泰德的记忆中所占据的样子。
It gets exaggerated.
它被夸大了。
Yeah, that's really cool to hear.
是的，听到这个真的很酷。
We do have a central kind of question about the show, like is what we're seeing on the TV show, is that the actual thing or is that Ted's memory of the thing?
我们确实对这部剧有一个核心的问题，比如我们在电视上看到的是真实发生的事情，还是泰德对这件事的记忆？
Cause it's like a weird thing because some of it is so heightened and strange.
因为这很诡异，有些部分太夸张、太奇怪了。
I think it was Ted's memory, right?
我觉得那是泰德的记忆，对吧？
Because a lot of the structure was pacing of like, no wait, that's not how it happens.
因为很多结构的节奏是这样的：等等，事情不是这样的。
And then you go back and say, but I guess that then we end up doing the one that Ted would say was the real version of it.
然后你回过头来说，但我想最后我们还是采用了泰德口中那个“真实版本”的呈现方式。
But no one's memory is photo-accurate either.
但也没有人的记忆能做到跟照片一模一样。
You know what keeps coming up?
你知道什么总是浮现在脑海里吗？
Neil, the episode showdown, the one we're in theoretically going to talk about at least a little in this talk.
尼尔，《决战》那一集，也就是我们这次访谈理论上至少要稍微聊聊的那一集。
Today we're talking about showdown, by the way, which aired on April 30th, 2007, written by Gloria Caledron Kellett.
顺便说一句，今天我们要聊的是《决战》，该集于2007年4月30日播出，由格洛丽亚·卡尔德隆·凯莱特编剧。
The daddy issues of it all.
关于恋父情结的种种。
Who is Barney's dad saying?
巴尼的爸爸在说谁？
We keep on coming up against another brilliant aspect of how you play the character, which is your mix, some of it was in the writing, but I think you really helped steer the writing this way, the mix between bravado and vulnerability and needing that vulnerability to earn the bravado, if that makes sense.
我们不断遇到你塑造这个角色的另一个精彩之处，那就是你将虚张声势与脆弱感完美结合，其中一部分体现在剧本中，但我觉得你真的帮着把剧本往这个方向引导，这种在虚张声势和脆弱感之间的平衡，而且需要这种脆弱感来支撑他的虚张声势，如果这说得通的话。
If you only have bravado and you don't have the, we don't get to peek under that suit, under that armor and see who really is, what his scars are, what got him where he is, I think the whole character doesn't work.
如果你只有虚张声势，却没有那种……我们没能一窥那套西装下、那层盔甲下的真实面目，看看他是谁、他的伤疤是什么、是什么造就了今天的他，我觉得整个角色就立不住了。
And I think you really understood that in a beautiful way.
我觉得你以一种非常美妙的方式真正理解了这一点。
This episode showdown, this is about, this is where we get, we get this delusional moment of Barney thinks Bob Barker is his dad, or does he really think that?
这一集《决战》，讲的是……这就是我们看到巴尼产生妄想的时刻，他以为鲍勃·巴克是他的爸爸，或者他真的那么想吗？
And in the end of the episode, there's this wonderful, it's clear Barney doesn't really think that he just needs to extend the denial.
而在这一集的结尾，有一个非常美妙的时刻，很显然巴尼并不真的那样认为，他只是需要延长这种否定状态。
How much were you aware in the moment of like, I've got to carve out that vulnerability to earn some of the cartoony craziness, because the vulnerability is like the, the foundation to to get to launch into the crazy.
你在当时有多大程度的意识，觉得自己必须刻画出这种脆弱感，来为那些卡通式的疯狂行为作支撑，因为脆弱感就像是……去开启疯狂状态的基础？
Yeah, that's a good question.
是的，这是个好问题。
I don't, I don't think I processed it in those ways mainly because I think I'm a fairly like vulnerable human.
我不觉得我是用这种方式去思考的，主要是因为我觉得自己本身就是一个挺脆弱的人。
And I think I was when, especially when we were filming this, I was less secure about who I was in my life as just a person.
而且我觉得当我……尤其是我们在拍摄这段的时候，作为一个普通人，我对我是谁其实并没有那么自信。
And so I was like, I was needy and insecure as an actor.
所以我当时就像个……作为一个演员，我是个既有需求又缺乏安全感的人。
I mean, I was playing Barney and I was like, I'm a fully formed human with flaws just like anybody.
我的意思是，我在扮演巴尼，而我想的是：我是一个有血有肉、和大家一样有着缺点的人。
But I think my flaws were like wanting approval.
但我认为我的缺点就是渴望得到认可。
And so that I think that innately plays through of the bravado.
所以我觉得这很自然地通过那种虚张声势表现了出来。
I never really, I mean, you guys can speak to this a little more than me cause I was sitting in it.
我从来没有真正……我的意思是，你们俩在这方面的发言权可能比我多，因为我是身处其中的那个人。
but I never really finished scenes and was like, Mike dropped, nailed it, walk away.
但我从来没有在拍完一场戏后觉得：完美收工，拿捏到位，潇洒走人。
Like I was always kind of like, do you think that's good?
我总是那种感觉：你觉得这演得好吗？
Yeah, yeah.
行，行。
Damn you, happy?
该死的，满意了吗？
If you're happy, I'm good.
如果你满意了，那我就好了。
But you wanna do it again?
但你想再拍一遍吗？
Like, I don't know.
总之，我不知道。
It's so weird.
这太奇怪了。
Most actors are incredibly confident in trusting in everything they do.
大多数演员对自己所做的一切都极其自信，深信不疑。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you New York City.
而这位老兄，他让我动心了，爱上了你，纽约市。
And now commercials.
现在进入广告。
end of commercials back to show.
广告结束，回到节目。
I think Jason really was because he's also a writer and had created other things himself.
我觉得杰森确实如此，因为他也是个编剧，自己还创作过其他东西。
Like he seemed very confident in the choices that he was making all the time.
他似乎对自己一直以来做出的选择信心十足。
And there was kind of a great, a great simple sort of singularity to his choices because, and that's what kind of grounded Marshall, I think, because he wasn't that insecure about his choices.
他的选择有一种很棒的、简单的单一性，因为……这也是马修这个角色能够落地生根的原因，我觉得，因为他对自己的选择并不那么缺乏安全感。
And he was always super pleased with how it was going.
而且他对事情的进展总是超级满意。
Yeah, I mean, like, yeah, I think he, I think he, uh, I don't want to speak for Jason.
对，我的意思是，对，我想他……我想他，呃，我不想替杰森代言。
And I hope we can talk to him about this one day, but I think he just like, I was, I always felt like Jason was a little more like he, he was doing a nine to five job.
我希望有一天我们能和他聊聊这个，但我觉得他只是……我总是觉得杰森更像是……他在做一份朝九晚五的工作。
That was a cool job and he would come in and he would do it and he wouldn't stress too much about it.
那是一份很酷的工作，他会来把它做好，而且不会为此感到太大压力。
And then he'd go home and go on his life and go out to dinner.
然后他会回家继续他的生活，出去吃晚饭。
And you know, I think like you and I, maybe it's like theater actors.
你知道的，我觉得就像你和我一样，也许就像戏剧演员那样。
Like if you, if you come from the theater, it's a little more like upset, you get a little more obsessive, I think, and I don't know.
如果你出身于戏剧界，就会更偏向于……你会变得更纠结、更有强迫症倾向，我想，我不知道。
I do have to say that part of what inspired this, my wife, Jordana, had never seen how I met your mother and she really wanted to watch it.
我必须得说，促成这件事的部分灵感来源是，我的妻子乔丹娜从来没看过《老爸老妈浪漫史》，她真的很想看。
And so I was going to do this re-watch and I reached out to Craig.
所以我打算重温这部剧，于是我联系了克雷格。
I was like, do you want to do something more formal?
我说：你想搞点更正式的形式吗？
Like it could be fun to revisit the show.
重新温习一下这部剧可能会挺有意思的。
And so she's been watching it with me and boy, when you get on the Price is Right with Bob Barker and that is like an opera.
所以她一直在陪我一起看，天哪，当你看到鲍勃·巴克的《价格猜猜猜》那一集时，那简直就像是一部歌剧。
That is like an unbelievable, because she was laughing so hard.
那简直不可思议，因为她笑得太厉害了。
We were both just dying, but I don't know, I hadn't seen it in so long, but you're, do you remember that day where you were on the set of the prices, right?
我们俩都笑得快不行了，但我不知道，我好久没看过它了，不过你……你还记得你在《价格猜猜猜》片场的那天吗？
The talk about kids in a candy store.
简直就是“进了糖果店的小孩”的最佳写照。
Incredibly vividly well.
记得非常生动清晰。
Did you grow up watching the prices right like you, Neil?
你小时候也像尼尔你一样，是看着《价格猜猜猜》长大的吗？
I grew up loving the prices right, obsessed with the prices right, obsessed with all things, game shows.
我从小就爱看《价格猜猜猜》，对它着迷，对各种游戏节目都着迷。
It was the sick day, the sick day treat and all sick day treats.
那是生病请假在家的奖赏，所有的生病假奖励。
So as I watched them all, it was daytime, daytime game shows.
所以我把它们全看了，那都是白天的节目，白天的游戏节目。
I would, I knew all of it.
我全都知道。
I know all of it.
我什么都知道。
I have box games that I've created.
我有自己制作的桌游。
I have a Netflix show called What's in the Box right now that I've seen for a gay guy.
我目前在Netflix上有一个叫《盒子里有什么》的节目，对于一个同性恋直男来说……
I really seem to like boxes.
我好像真的很喜欢盒子。
But the Bob Barker, I was obsessed.
但对于鲍勃·巴克，我真的着迷。
And before we had gone to tape it, I was able to go.
在我们去录制之前，我有机会去现场看了一下。
It must have been during the run of Jaime and your because of the CVS connection, I went for a real taping and stood in the back and watched everything.
那一定是在我演《老爸老妈》期间，因为哥伦比亚广播公司的关系，我去现场看了一次真正的录制，站在后排观看了整个过程。
And I was like, an actual kid in the candy store.
当时我真的就像个进了糖果店的小孩。
Couldn't believe that it was happening.
简直不敢相信这一切正在发生。
Looked at the Plinko thing move.
看着帕林科（Plinko）游戏板在动。
But that was before you knew we were doing an episode there, right?
但那是在你知道我们要去那里拍一集之前，对吧？
Correct, 100% correct.
没错，百分之百正确。
So when you, I remember that day, Neil, and I knew how important it was to you.
所以当你在……尼尔，我记得那一天，我知道这对于你有多重要。
I knew you were obsessed with Price's Ride, Carter and I were too, that's why we wrote the episode, but like, I remember feeling nervous for you almost.
我知道你对《价格猜猜猜》痴迷，卡特和我也是，这就是我们写这一集的原因，但我记得我甚至有点为你感到紧张。
I was like, you had to go and like, part of it, you were acting in front of the price as right audience, right?
我就觉得，你不得不去，而且部分原因是你当时是在《价格猜猜猜》的真实观众面前演戏，对吧？
We had a audience there for a bunch of it.
我们现场有一大群观众。
I remember being like, Neil has to pull off a lot.
我记得当时觉得，尼尔必须得顶住很大的压力。
We have this little tiny amount of time on this fucking, forgive me, legendary set of the price is right.
我们在那个他妈的——原谅我——传奇的《价格猜猜猜》片场只有这么一点点可怜的时间。
It's very daunting.
这非常令人畏惧。
It's what we watched when we're homesick, when we're eight years old.
那是我们八岁生病时在家里看的东西。
And here you are having to act with Bob Barker saying things like, are you saying you're proud of me?
而你现在却得和鲍勃·巴克演对手戏，还得说出诸如“你是说你为我感到骄傲吗？”这样的话。
And being your tears.
眼里还含着泪水。
I remember asking you guys, like is Bob gonna play along?
我记得我当时问你们，鲍勃会配合吗？
Like what was his temperament like?
他的脾气怎么样？
Cause he was a very lovely guy.
因为他是个非常可爱的人。
He got it, right?
他懂的，对吧？
I thought he was amazing, actually.
其实我觉得他棒极了。
Yeah.
对。
And he got thought you can play in the reel.
而且他觉得你可以在片中大显身手。
What was the movie he did?
他演过什么电影来着？
Happy Gilmore.
《高尔夫球终结者》。
He did happy Gilmore.
他演了《高尔夫球终结者》。
He was really funny, Matt.
他真的很搞笑，马特。
And he did physical comedy in that.
而且他在里面演了动作喜剧。
And he had a stunt double, I think.
我想他当时甚至有个替身。
And so I think he knew Adam Sandler, which kind of calmed me.
所以我想他认识亚当·桑德勒，这让我稍微冷静了一些。
So I felt safe to do sort of that version of it.
因此我觉得可以安全地演那种版本的戏。
The stuff I was super happy with is that he let me like hug him in earnest.
让我最开心的一点是，他真的让我好好拥抱了他。
Like he could have said, like, let's do a easier hug or something.
他本来可以说，比如，我们来个简单点的拥抱什么的。
but he was, he was so game and down with all of it that, and I'd watched so much Price is Right, that I loved when I did the re-watch, just now I was laughing at myself when I was going, like looking at the audience, like, come on, come on, guys.
但他非常配合，对所有这些都欣然接受，而且我看过太多《价格猜猜猜》了，以至于刚才重看时，我看着自己冲观众挑动眉毛说“来吧，来吧，伙计们”，我都忍不住笑话自己。
Yeah.
对。
Cause you know, you're a savant.
因为你知道，你是个天才。
Barney is literally a savant down to this.
巴尼简直是个这方面的天才。
And also, this is another like magical, how I met my thing.
而且，这也是另一个神奇的、属于《老爸老妈浪漫史》的时刻。
He gets it down to the dollar.
他精确到了美元。
He doesn't miss by one number.
他连一个数字都不会猜错。
He doesn't miss by one ounce.
他连一盎司都不会差。
Yeah, I actually forgotten the end of the episode.
是的，我其实把这集的结尾给忘了。
So when I was, Barney was contemplating the numbers and said, 18, one, eight, six, four, one.
所以当巴尼在琢磨数字并说出18、1、8、6、4、1时。
Then I was thinking, oh, wow, wait, did this end?
我当时还在想，哦，等等，这是要收尾了吗？
Because he intentionally went over by $1 or something?
因为他是故意多猜了1美元还是什么的？
I was confused at the actual $1, so no, I was excited for him.
我对实际的1美元感到很困惑，所以不，我当时为他感到兴奋。
Oh my God.
天哪。
The saddest moment for me so far of how I met your mother and also the funniest, is the flashback.
到目前为止，对我来说《老爸老妈浪漫史》中最悲伤的时刻，也是最搞笑的时刻，就是这段闪回。
But when little Barney says, wanna play catch?
当小巴尼说：“想玩接球吗？”
Oh, the baseball queen roasting the baseball at the TV.
哦，棒球女王把棒球砸向电视机。
That may be the saddest scene I ever shot in the history of cinema.
这可能是我在电影史上拍过的最悲伤的场景了。
It's the perfect bounce, unbelievable.
那一下反弹太完美了，简直不可思议。
Neil, I noticed there was a little moment.
尼尔，我注意到有一个小细节。
Just the things we're catching.
这就是我们注意到的东西。
There's a moment where you don't have any dialogue.
有一个镜头你没有任何台词。
Bob Barker is talking, you're standing next to him.
鲍勃·巴克在说话，你站在他旁边。
And I noticed you're trying to stand like him to be more like your dad.
我注意到你在模仿他的站姿，好让自己更像你爸爸。
Yes, I noticed that too.
对，我也注意到了。
It was so fucking funny.
太他妈搞笑了。
I edited that episode.
我剪辑了那一集。
I watched that episode a hundred times the other room.
我在另一个房间把那一集看了上百遍。
I don't think I ever noticed that exact moment.
我好像从来没注意到那个确切的瞬间。
And that's how in you were, that's how in finding every, you were alive in every little moment in that.
可见你当时有多入戏，你在每一个微小的瞬间都表现得多么充满活力。
And it's so insane.
这太疯狂了。
It's insane that he thinks Bob Barker is his dad.
他居然以为鲍勃·巴克是他爸爸，这太疯狂了。
It's insane that he goes up right away.
他立刻走过去的行为也太疯狂了。
But you make it seem plausible.
但你把它演得很合理。
There's a beating heart behind it.
这一切背后有一颗跳动的心。
I feel like that's a very Barney thing.
我觉得这非常符合巴尼的风格。
is like he has this utterly clinically insane idea that everyone around him is fully agreed.
就好像他脑子里有一个完全临床疯狂的想法，而他周围的每个人都完全默认了。
This is insane.
这太疯狂了。
And he's like, yeah, like this is, of course, like he's trying to get everyone to sign off on his version of reality, like a lot.
而他却觉得，是的，这当然是……他就像这样试图让每个人都接受他那套疯狂的现实版本。
And it's bonkers.
这简直荒谬透顶。
Let's also remember that I don't think it was out of the realm of possibility that you wouldn't write that Bob Barker was his actual father.
我们还得记住，你们当时写鲍勃·巴克就是他亲生父亲，这并不是完全不可能的事情。
You hadn't said to us like, oh, by the way, we have a whole arc for him where he needs his father at that point.
你们之前并没有对我们说：“哦，对了，我们为他设计了一条完整的故事线，他到那个时候需要找到他的父亲。”
Right.
没错。
We didn't know it yet.
我们当时还不知道。
But if you were not Barney and then Barney, as we know Barney, comes in and says, yeah, how barkin' from the price is right is my dad?
但如果不是巴尼，然后我们所熟知的那个巴尼走过来，说：“是的，那个来自《价格猜猜猜》的鲍勃·巴金是我爸？”
You'd be like, dude, do we need to take you in?
你一定会说：“老兄，我们需要把你送进去看看吗？”
Is everything okay?
一切都还好吧？
Calm down, medicine?
冷静点，吃药了吗？
For sure.
肯定的。
But like on this show also like Britney Spears was.
但在这种剧里，布兰妮·斯皮尔斯也曾……
Yeah, like we were friends with Regent.
对，就像我们和瑞吉交朋友一样。
Yeah, Secretary.
对，秘书。
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
So, so for a while when we were filming it, I was thinking it like, I don't know, as I'm recollecting it, I don't, I think I was believing that he was my father.
所以，所以在我们拍摄的有一段时间里，我一直在想，我不知道，现在回忆起来，我当时好像真的相信他就是我爸。
Yeah.
对。
Because you play it.
因为你的表演就是这样的。
Flashback scenes have been that he was told that's his dad.
闪回的场景一直在暗示那是他的爸爸。
And you see like the camera zooms in on his faces, he recognizes his dad.
你可以看到镜头拉近到他的脸上，他认出了自己的父亲。
And then there's all these different versions of him growing up talking to his dad.
然后还有他从小到大跟父亲说话的各种不同版本的画面。
I think he really thought it was his dad.
我想他是真的以为那是他爸爸。
And I think that there was a world where Bob Barker could have really been his dad.
而且我觉得在某个平行世界里，鲍勃·巴克真的完全可能就是他爸。
Right.
没错。
It's we it could have gone that way.
我们本来可以让剧情这样发展。
And it almost getting side to side.
而且差一点就真的这么发展了。
I you can buy it.
你完全可以相信。
I totally would buy it.
我绝对会相信。
It's Barney has to get to that moment of almost saying it to Bob.
巴尼必须走到那个差点对鲍勃说出口的瞬间。
And that's the moment he realizes like, this probably isn't true.
那就是他意识到“这大概不是真的”的时刻。
I played that in scene for real.
我当时是真情实感地在演那场戏。
You did.
你确实是。
Like now I'm a little embarrassed and I'm getting sweaty as I'm saying.
就好像我现在觉得有点尴尬，说这话时都在冒汗。
No, no, no, I didn't play that last scene with the vulnerability of Barney knowing that that if he If he tells the truth and then he knows that it's not his dad and he's and he's somehow covering for that by making up Fact that that if he told Bob it would end him I was playing it as if he really sort of thought if I tell him he's my dad He would it would hurt his life.
不，不，不，我演最后那场戏时，带有一种巴尼式的脆弱感：他知道，如果他说出真相，他就知道那不是他爸爸，而他正在通过编造一个事实来掩盖这一点——如果他把这告诉鲍勃，会毁了鲍勃的生活。我当时演出的感觉是，如果我告诉他他是我爸，这会伤害到他的人生。
I Think you played it right like I think you actually played it because I think it's more compelling to watch a person and who's gonna ride this from all the way into the sand.
我觉得你处理得对，我的意思是，实际上你演得很对，因为我觉得看着一个人一意孤行、直到最后，其实更有吸引力。
Like you're not gonna give it up, you're not gonna like come to, because I think one of the great things about Barney is like even though he changed, he never changed.
就像你不会放弃，你不会妥协，因为我觉得巴尼最棒的一点在于，尽管他变了，但他从未改变。
Like there's something about, I actually, the editor who edited both my movies said, the difference between movies and TV show is a movie, you have to transform them into ours.
有种感觉……实际上，剪辑过我两部电影的剪辑师曾说过，电影和电视剧的区别在于，电影里你必须让角色发生转变。
They're different at the end.
到了结尾时他们已经不同了。
But with a TV show, you have to maintain some stasis, so people watch over and over.
但对于电视剧，你必须保持某种静态平衡，这样人们才会一遍又一遍地看。
So the characters have to transform way slower, especially if you're doing nine years.
所以角色的转变必须慢得多，特别是如果你要做九年的话。
It's why I'm a staunch supporter of the ending of the whole show.
这也是为什么我是整部剧结局的坚定支持者。
I get asked that a lot.
我经常被问到这个问题。
Like, what do you think of the ending?
比如，你怎么看这个结局？
And I'm like a big proponent and an active fan of it.
而我是它的坚定支持者和狂热粉丝。
This is gonna cause a couple of news articles, by the way, to be written about this, because anytime I mention the finale, it's like people, literally people write about it, literally.
顺便说一句，这会引发几篇关于这方面的新闻报道，因为每当我提到大结局，人们——真的是人们就会写文章讨论它，千真万确。
But because of what you say, Josh, is what I think is, and it's how I explain it.
但正如你所说，乔什，我觉得这就是原因，这也是我的解释方式。
I think Barney is, and throughout that entire run of the show has always been that guy.
我觉得巴尼在整部剧的播出过程中，一直都是那样的人。
He's not gonna change.
他不会改变。
And I think that it was short, it would be short-sided and like real TV sitcom logic to all of a sudden say, you know, A.O.N.T.
而且我觉得如果改变太快，那就太短视了，也太符合传统电视情景喜剧的套路了，突然说，你知道的，巴尼最后幸福地结婚了。
winds up happily married.
（注：原文A.O.N.T.为语音识别错误或代指，此处根据上下文意译）
Evolution is slow.
演变是缓慢的。
Evolution is a slow process.
演变是一个缓慢的过程。
It doesn't happen right away.
它不会马上发生。
hopefully, you see Barney evolve as we flash forward through years ahead past that point.
希望在之后的闪现镜头中，你能看到巴尼在那个时间点之后的岁月里逐渐进化。
You see evolution starting to happen for him, but it's true.
你能看到他开始发生变化，但确实如此。
It does not happen overnight at the same time.
它不会在一夜之间发生。
Do you know what we keep saying even two seasons of watching this and doing this podcast for these two seasons, Barney is right a lot of the time he has and he's insane a lot of the time.
你知道我们看了两季、做这个播客两季以来一直在说什么吗？巴尼很多时候都是对的，而且他很多时候也很疯狂。
But we're noticing there's a lot of moments where Barney, like there's this episode or a little earlier in season two where Ted is going to move in with Robin and Barney sits head down at the bar and says, no, you're not.
但我们注意到有很多时刻，巴尼——就像这一集，或者第二季稍早的时候，泰德打算搬去和罗宾一起住，而巴尼坐在酒吧里垂头丧气地说，不，你不会的。
This isn't real.
这不是真的。
Every time you talk about it, you don't call it your apartment, you call it Robin's apartment.
每次你谈到它，你都不叫它你的公寓，你叫它罗宾的公寓。
And like, there's just like these very emotionally, like these little moments of clarity.
就像这样，有这些非常情绪化的、非常小的清醒时刻。
And it's almost always in the context of Barney being a fucking great friend, because he really does love Ted.
而且几乎总是在巴尼是个他妈的好朋友的语境下，因为他是真的很爱泰德。
He really does love Marshall and Lily.
他是真的很爱马歇尔和莉莉。
What I totally had forgotten, Barney flies to San Francisco to talk sense into Lily, right to get her to come back to Marshall like he saves that relationship and and like I had completely forgotten that and he there are these moments like yes he wants to get laid yes he want but nothing means more to him than his friends like there's a kind of loyalty to his friends that is very so sweet like his chosen family for sure yeah it's his chosen family yeah No, it keeps coming up.
我完全忘了一点，巴尼飞到旧金山去劝莉莉，为了让她回到马歇尔身边——他拯救了那段关系，而且——我完全把这事忘了，他有这些时刻，是的，他想打炮，是的，他想……但没有什么比他的朋友更重要，他对朋友有一种非常非常甜蜜的忠诚，绝对是他自己选择的家人，是的，这是他选择的家人，没错。不，这事总被提起。
It's like, it's actually like way more prevalent than I remember it being in the first two seasons.
就像，这其实比我记忆中在前两季里出现的频率要高得多。
Barney's stories are often not about chasing women at all.
巴尼的故事往往根本不是关于追女生的。
They're often about friendship.
它们往往是关于友谊的。
He just wants to be...
他只是想……
And the mystery of the dude allowed you guys as writers, I think, to have him be able to randomly go and fly somewhere to prove a point to come back.
这个家伙身上的神秘感，我认为允许你们作为编剧，让他能够随意去某个地方飞一趟，去证明一个观点然后再回来。
Yeah, right.
是的，没错。
Right.
没错。
Yeah.
对。
The ambiguous.
那种模棱两可。
And even you remember that, remember that scorpion in the tote episode, Neil, where Barney keeps taking all the women from Marshall, who's now single, who's now, who's in season two.
而且你甚至还记得，尼尔，还记得那集《蝎子与手提袋》吗？巴尼不断地从现在单身的马歇尔身边抢走所有的女人，当时是第二季。
Yeah.
对。
He keeps stealing all the women.
他一直把所有的女人都抢走。
He's helping Marshall and he's like, now I'm going to take, I'm going to check.
他在帮马歇尔，他说，现在我要把……我要去看看。
And he throws the number out of the cabin, Marshall gets out of the cab, but then he has it up his sleeve.
然后他把号码从出租车里扔出去，马歇尔下了车，但他其实把号码藏在袖子里。
Like there's all these like, and we were like, Oh my God, Barney's so horrible in this episode, But then 12, 15 episodes later, you realize he says to Lily, I can't keep stealing all these women from Marshall to keep him on ice for you.
就像所有这些——我们当时想，哦天哪，巴尼在这集里太混蛋了，但接着过了12到15集，你意识到他对莉莉说，我不能一直从马歇尔身边抢走所有这些女人来为你把他“冷冻保鲜”起来。
He says, he has a great line, he says, Marshall's the best, and there's only a matter of time until another woman sees that.
他说了一句很棒的话，他说，马歇尔是最棒的，别的女人迟早会发现这一点的。
So get back to New York City now.
所以现在就回纽约去吧。
It's a whole scene where Lily doesn't say a word.
整场戏里莉莉一句话都没说。
It's in San Francisco, Barney flies there and he's wearing the same suit.
那是远在旧金山，巴尼飞过去时还穿着同一套西装。
He does not let Lily even speak.
他甚至不让莉莉说话。
He closes the door and flies back to New York, and that is what got her back, and that's what got them married.
他关上门，飞回纽约，这就是他追回她的方式，也是他们结婚的原因。
And Barney becomes Marshall's best man in that episode because he's earned it.
在那集里，巴尼成了马修的伴郎，因为这是他应得的。
And it's great, and a lot of it is about that with Barney.
这太棒了，而且巴尼的很多故事都与此有关。
It's cool, you think of Barney as this womanizer, and it's the playbook, and it says, it's really not a lot of the show.
这很酷，你以为巴尼是个花花公子，有把妹手册，但其实剧里并不全是这样。
Can I ask a writer-shroom question?
我能问一个编剧室的问题吗？
Because what I realize in the nine seasons of this show is that I never, ever went into the writer's room.
因为我意识到在这剧的九季里，我从来、从来没有进过编剧室。
I mean maybe three times yeah, I would sort of come and visit maybe more in the last season of like hey It's the last season, but I never really felt Welcome And I don't mean that disrespectfully.
我是说也许去过三次吧，我偶尔会去串个门，最后一季可能去得勤点，心想“嘿，这是最后一季嘛”，但我从来没有真正觉得受到欢迎，我这话没有不尊重人的意思。
It's just like it was a different room and a different world and when I did go and sit there It was like weird.
就好像那是另一个房间，另一个世界，当我真的去那里坐着的时候，感觉很诡异。
It was like the energy had shifted because now like the person that you're writing about and pitching jokes Oh, it's now like sitting there and then self-consciousness.
就好像气场变了，因为现在你所扮演、供他们抛梗的那个本人，就坐在那里，然后就会感到不自在。
So I just never went yeah But when when you're in the writer's room in like the situation that you're talking about now, did you guys?
所以我从来不去，对。但是当你们在编剧室里，比如像你刚才说的这种情况，你们大家——
Intend for Barney to have the pathos that he did or in like that scene with Marshall stealing and Barney stealing all things Was it was that just a comedy driver that Barney would steal all his girls and only 10 12 episodes later?
是不是一开始就打算让巴尼展现出后来的那种深情？还是说像马修和巴尼抢东西的那场戏，巴尼抢走了他所有的女孩，仅仅过10到12集之后——
Did you did you think oh we can reconnect that?
你们当时有没有想过“哦，我们可以把这个串联起来”？
Yeah, I think with that one specifically I think it was only comedy at the time, and then we sort of in a few episodes, but we were like, God, Barney was a fucking dick in that one.
对，我觉得具体到那一次，当时纯粹是为了喜剧效果，然后过了几集，我们就在想：“天哪，巴尼那集简直是个混蛋。”
How can this be clever?
怎么才能把这变得聪明点？
There's more to Barney than this.
巴尼的内涵不止于此。
There's something about Barney and your performance of him that made the writers, made all this want to peel back the layers.
关于巴尼以及你对这个角色的演绎，有些东西让编剧们、让所有人都想要剥开他的外衣。
It was just like this onion, like, what's underneath this?
就像剥洋葱一样，想看看这下面是什么？
What makes him this way?
是什么造就了这样的他？
And I think part of it is how fully inhabited you were in the part.
我觉得部分原因是你对角色的完美诠释。
And there was something like, well, what's beneath this though and it was just like psychologically fascinating to sort of dig into that and I think that's what I mean the chemistry between you and the writers whether or not you were literally in the room there was something about the mystery and the power of that performance that were like we got to understand this guy more and whatever it was it sent us kind of excavating into him and we said you know what it could be it could be that he had a grand plan about this Marshall thing because he actually does love Marshall tremendously much in some ways that it is it's It's what you said, it's his chosen family.
有种感觉是，这背后究竟是什么？深入挖掘这一点在心理上太迷人了。这就是我的意思，你和编剧之间的化学反应，不管你当时是不是真的坐在编剧室里，那种表演的神秘感和力量感让觉得我们必须更多地了解这个家伙，无论如何，这促使我们开始挖掘他的内心，我们说，你知道吗，原因可能是这样的：他对马修的事情有个宏伟的计划，因为他确实非常非常爱马修，在某些方面，正如你所说，这是他自己选择的家人。
I love that.
我太喜欢这个了。
He is the way he is because he does not have the family.
他之所以是现在这样，是因为他没有家庭。
He has a great brother and his mom is complicated, but it's his mom, but he never had a dad and he's felt lonely and he would die for these friends.
他有个很好的哥哥，他的妈妈情况比较复杂，但那是他妈妈，可他从来没有过父亲，他一直感到孤独，而他会为了这些朋友去死。
He would, these friends are the most important to him.
他真的会，这些朋友对他是最重要的。
It was one of the greatest joys of the whole show was the experience of sitting to read a new episode.
整部剧最大的乐趣之一，就是坐下来阅读新一集剧本的经历。
Yeah, I agree.
是的，我同意。
Sitting by myself, reading it, because we didn't know, you guys never ever, once really drunk at a Christmas party, you said, do you want to know at the end?
一个人坐着读，因为我们并不知道，你们从来没有——除了有一次在一个圣诞派对上喝得酩酊大醉时，你问过：“你想知道结局吗？”
This is where you did the game.
就是你玩那个游戏的时候。
I think at season seven something.
我想大概是第七季左右吧。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
When you had finally fully cracked it in a way.
当时你们终于以某种方式完全理清了头绪。
And I didn't really want to know, but I think it wasn't until then, like seven years in.
我其实不想知道，但我觉得直到那时，也就是七年之后。
And so I didn't know any of it.
所以我什么都不知道。
And you were.
而你。
And you said, no, I said, good, I'll tell ya.
你说，不，我说，好吧，那我告诉你。
I'll tell ya, the matter.
我告诉你，没关系。
Do you know what that strikes me as Neil is like, When you're on the show, especially if it's a good show, there's a weird thing where you're on the show, you're playing the character, you're in the ensemble, but you're also a fan of the show.
尼尔，你知道这给我什么感觉吗？就像当你参演这部剧时，尤其是如果这是一部好剧，会有种奇怪的现象：你参演了这部剧，你在扮演角色，你是剧组的一员，但你同时也是这部剧的粉丝。
So you're first and only almost like first response of like getting to appreciate it as a fan is sitting by yourself and reading the episode.
所以你作为粉丝去欣赏它的第一反应、也是几乎唯一的反应，就是自己一个人坐着读剧本。
Yeah, 100%.
是的，百分之百。
Because otherwise then you enter into the thing.
因为否则的话，你就要进入拍摄状态了。
Yeah.
是的。
Sure, and as a Tiki element of just like, I'm gonna get to do this next week.
当然，还有一种小小的期待感，就像“我下周要演这个了”。
Yeah.
是的。
I'm going to play a hairdresser that's super zesty.
我要演一个超级有活力的美发师。
Okay, that'll be fun, but I love that.
好吧，那会很有趣，但我太喜欢了。
You know what made a couple of things you just made us laugh when you marry Marshall and Lily, when you're the aficion, you're, you did this a couple of times in this show, but like talking through tears, like trying not to cry, Barney.
你知道吗，有几件事让我们笑了，当你们让马修和莉莉结婚时，当你是那个证婚人——你在剧里这么干过好几次——带着哭腔说话，极力忍住不哭的巴尼。
It's a good voice.
这声音真不错。
声音很好听。
It's a good voice.
And also when people ask me what was the hardest you laughed on set.
还有，当人们问我你在片场笑得最厉害的一次是什么时候。
In a Riva Deirci Fierro, when you do that thing where they say, I thought you loved the Fierro and he says, love it and you turn to the wall and you do that.
在里瓦·代尔奇·菲耶罗那一集，当你做那个动作时，他们说，我以为你爱菲耶罗，而他说，爱死啦，然后你转向墙壁，做了那个动作。
I hate it.
我讨厌它。
You remember that?
你还记得吗？
I hate it.
我讨厌它。
I remember it very well.
我记得很清楚。
I remember one last week too.
我也记得上周的一个。
When you first did it, it crushed all of us.
你第一次做的时候，我们所有人都笑喷了。
And then I had, I was a breaker.
然后我就，我很容易笑场。
You're not a breaker.
你才不是容易笑场的人。
We do say this, that you were the least breaky.
我们确实说过这个，你是最不容易笑场的。
I think of everyone.
我觉得在所有人当中。
You did not break very often.
你很少笑场。
That's really true.
确实如此。
What you did, it was for real.
你笑场的时候，那是真情流露。
but it was rare, you know?
但那很少见，你知道吗？
Seagull broke you up now and again.
海鸥（Seagull）偶尔会让你笑场。
I feel like Seagull would do some weird shit that would break you.
我觉得海鸥会做一些奇怪的破事让你笑场。
But it was, I mean, you broke once a season.
但也就是，我是说，你一季也就笑场一次。
Like that way, you really, you're very good at the dead.
就那种，你真的很擅长保持严肃。
You held it.
你忍住了。
Seagull broke us all when he had the pants that Lily was trying to get him to not, the MC Hammer pants.
海鸥穿着莉莉千方百计想让他脱掉的那条裤子时，我们全都被他逗笑了，那条MC·哈默式的裤子。
Oh my God, I remember that.
哦天哪，我记得那个。
But also, Neil, one thing that we keep commenting on is the swiftness with which you're able to make some of these turns.
还有，尼尔，我们一直赞不绝口的一点是，你能如此迅速地完成其中一些情绪的转变。
like when James says that they're having a son and he's like, there's going to be a baby.
就像詹姆斯说他们要生个儿子，然后他说，要有个孩子了。
Like that, do you remember that?
就像那样，你还记得吗？
You're railing against marriage.
你之前还在痛斥婚姻。
We're having to make a baby.
我们要生个孩子了。
Just on a dime.
说变就变。
Like it almost strikes me as like slaloming down a hill and like clearing like a really hard flag or something.
这让我感觉就像在山坡上玩回转滑雪，然后像越过一个非常艰难的旗门什么的。
Like just your turns are so sharp and so swift.
你的转折就是这么急促，这么迅速。
Like is that just something instinctual to you as a comic actor?
这对于你作为一名喜剧演员来说是一种本能吗？
maybe.
也许吧。
Thank you.
谢谢。
That's very sweet.
这太贴心了。
I knew that we were doing a comedy, right?
我知道我们在拍喜剧，对吧？
So I was really, I was really focused on the form.
所以我真的很专注，我非常专注于表现形式。
So I was sort of trying to channel my best Carol Burnett shows and, you know, three companies and things.
所以我有点像是在展现我最好的卡罗尔·伯内特秀，还有，你知道的，《三人行》之类的情景喜剧。
Because we were all, we were all, I was worried that we were going to get canceled all the time and like we were all, I seemed a little concerned about why it wasn't getting a bigger reaction sooner and we were working really hard and we were sort of maybe getting picked up and then like and by the way these final four shows all get picked up.
因为我们都在，我们都在，我一直担心我们的节目随时会被砍掉，而且我们都在，我似乎有点担心为什么它没有更快地得到更大的反响，我们工作非常努力，我们可能有点快要获得续订了，然后就像，顺便说一句，这最后四个节目都获得了续订。
There was no heralding about it and so So, you know, I was cozying up to less moon bez and cozying up to the fox heads as much as I could and as much as I was able because I was also for just longevity.
当时对此没有任何大肆宣扬，所以，你知道的，我尽可能地去讨好莱斯·穆恩韦斯（Les Moonves），尽可能地去讨好福克斯的高层，只要我能做到，也是为了长远发展。
So I was in those scenes, I was trying to be as fucking funny and as...
所以我在那些场景里，我努力表现得他妈的搞笑，还有……
We were saying for our suppers.
我们在为生计而演。
Yeah.
是啊。
Could you argue that that was good?
你能说那是件好事吗？
That kept us all very alert, like those whole...
这让我们所有人都保持高度警惕，就像那些整个……
It wasn't like we were a huge hit, it was I think you referenced this earlier, Josh, like Maybe it was good that we were also hungry.
我们并不是什么超级大热门，我想你之前也提到过，约什，也许我们当时也有点饥饿感是件好事。
I felt that way as a writer.
作为编剧，我也有这种感觉。
The writers didn't felt that way like, we've got to keep surprising people.
编剧们也有这种感觉，我们得不断给人们带来惊喜。
We've got to find new things that hook people in.
我们必须找到能吸引人们的新东西。
We've got to find things that get attention.
我们必须找到能引起关注的东西。
We did, we were not coasting.
我们确实做到了，我们没有得过且过。
We were not right.
我们没有。
We were not taking anything for granted, any of us.
我们没有把任何事情当成理所当然，我们所有人都没有。
And it's hard to understand that because the show became a big hit.
这很难理解，因为后来这部剧成了大热门。
And in some ways has become an even bigger hit since they went off the air and other generations are finding it.
在某种程度上，自从我们停播后，它甚至变得更火了，更多的年轻一代正在发现它。
People, the younger folks listening to this podcast might not realize like, we were not secure at all in season two.
人们，听这个播客的年轻人可能没有意识到，我们在第二季的时候一点安全感都没有。
We did not know two, three, two, three, four, maybe four, five is when we exhale.
我们不知道第二季，第三季，第二季，第三季，第四季，也许到了第四、五季我们才松了一口气。
When we got a two season pick up, right?
当我们获得两季续订的时候，对吧？
What's that?
什么？
I think that might have been four, like four, five.
我想那可能是在第四季，比如第四、五季。
Yeah, that was when it started.
对，就是从那时候开始的。
Yeah, because once we got our fourth season, then we were in syndication.
对，因为一旦我们拿到了第四季，我们就能进行联合播出（syndication）了。
That meant 100 episodes, which means that we could then have, and so that was the big turning point, like if we can get a season four pick up, then we might go six or seven seasons because then they'll have more vested interests to have more episodes.
这意味着100集，这意味着我们可以拥有，所以那是一个巨大的转折点，如果我们能获得第四季的续订，那么我们可能会拍六季或七季，因为这样他们就会有更多既得利益来制作更多的集数。
I also forgot Craig didn't lifetime pick us up and start airing old episodes or something like they did when it when it when it's all this indication and they were sort of first to slap it on there.
我差点忘了，Lifetime电视台也买下了我们并开始播放旧剧集什么的，就像他们在联合播出时做的那样，他们算是第一批把它搬上荧幕的。
And but we got on a Netflix even before the first thing that looks changed everything and everything and all of a sudden we're like wait a second we're this is happening.
但我们在Netflix上线的速度甚至比第一件事还要早，这改变了一切，一切都改变了，突然之间我们觉得，等一下，这正在发生。
People are people are consuming the show and the way it's sort of is meant to be consumed in this obsessive way and all those details and all those setups and payoffs and it's a soap opera like it was we were the right show for for this new technology that was coming.
人们，人们正在以一种本应被消费的方式，以这种痴迷的方式观看这部剧，所有那些细节，所有那些铺垫和回报，它就像是一部肥皂剧，我们就是适应即将到来的这种新技术的完美剧集。
I always kind of felt that that my performance annoyed you, Josh.
我一直觉得我的表演惹恼了你，约什。
What?
什么？
And on that, the rare cliffhanger we invite you to join us next week for the exciting conclusion of how we met Neil Patrick Harris.
带着这个罕见的悬念，我们邀请您下周继续收看《老爸老妈浪漫史》幕后揭秘的精彩大结局。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《老爸老妈浪漫史幕后揭秘》（How We Made Your Mother）由约什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）和克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）主持并担任执行制片人，由Office Ladies Network和Audyssey联合呈献并发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集的执行制片人还有珍娜·费舍（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我（亚历克·莱夫，Alex Lev）制作和剪辑，我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡（Doug Matica）。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是Point of Blue Studios的亚历克斯·里夫斯（Alex Reeves）。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，又名Z世代大师，是艾米莉·布伦贝格（Emily Blumberg）。
Artwork by John Morrow.
美术设计由约翰·莫罗（John Morrow）完成。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这确实对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是由我们自己的约什·拉德纳创作的《纽约市》（New York City），克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基（Andrew Majuski）提供了额外音乐。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢罗拉·肯尼迪（Lola Kennedy）和埃利奥特·康纳斯（Elliot Connors）。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
请在 Substack 上订阅约什·拉德纳的新闻通讯，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐及其他作品。
After Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasWriter.com.
去各大书店购买克雷格·托马斯的第一部小说《事情不是这样的》（That's Not How It Happened），并在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上查看他发表的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
您还可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的“死去的父亲协会”（Dead Fathers Society）。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解更多关于您如何能产生影响的信息，即本节目为先天性小儿心脏病研究筹款的持续活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“产生影响”（Make a Difference）标签页。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，他会跳舞。